vladland tatasky was one of Russia's
most prominent military bloggers on the
war in Ukraine last Sunday he was killed
in an explosion at a cafe in Saint
Petersburg the Russian authorities were
investigating it as an act of terrorism
a large number of his supporters
gathered for his funeral in Moscow he
was known for his vocal support of the
invasion of Ukraine Russian
investigators have arrested and charged
a 26 year old woman in connection with
his death Al jazeera's dorsa Jabari was
at that funeral in Moscow
the head of the Wagner group of Guinea
pregosian who was one of the first
people to pay his respects to the coffin
of the 40 year old vladylin tartarsky
earlier he said that he was a proud
proud member of this uh movement really
and posthumously has been made a member
of the Wagner group as well he was given
a sledgehammer on the coffin that was
inscribed with his name and thoughts
that the Wagner group conveyed in their
appreciation for the work that he did we
also spoke to a number of people who
knew tartarsky one of his closest
friends that we spoke to said that this
is really a day of celebrating his life
they are not here to really mourn him
but to celebrate his achievements he's
being hailed as a hero of Russia and
that he wanted one thing and one thing
only and that is for Russia to be
victorious in the war in Ukraine we also
saw a number of politicians paying their
respects at this event which is heavily
heavily guarded by Security Forces there
was a number of barricades as well as
metal detectors that have been put up
around the cemetery to control the
crowds that were coming in
Pavel Falcon Height as a defense and
Military analyst he joins us now live
via Skype from Moscow good to have you
with us Pavel he was lauded as a
national hero at his funeral today but
was he
well he was uh well known and maybe a
hero for those who supported his
position
but I believe this funeral uh yes there
was a brigortion the leader of the
Wagner group some politicians but what
was absent was Russian official then and
represent High representatives of the
defense Ministry that is fighting the
war with Ukraine so to some extent he
was a controversial figure because well
the official is the Russian officials
tried to kind of well separate
themselves from him
conventional Legacy Media I I still wear
most people in Russia get their news and
we know that the the news in in Russia
is heavily controlled by the Kremlin
what what role do these military
bloggers play in in getting their
message and the kremlin's message out to
the audience in Russia
oh yes the the news cycle is very much
controlled then you kind of criticism or
uh coming from inside is right now
suppressed from practically fully those
who criticize the reward have to do that
from abroad and from with inside Russia
you have these military correspondence
of different media organizations or
military also bloggers who are kind of
self-employed and they sometimes do
criticize the execution of the Special
Operation not the operation itself that
they that they support but there's been
lots of mismanagement they're critical
of the quite often of the military High
command as is the if any precaution the
chief of Wagner grew a mercenary groups
that means that the
are these influencers
are
not always total in tune with the
Russian official them the woman's been
arrested uh Pavel in connection with the
explosion that killed tatasky what do
you make of of her motives who would be
behind uh this who would want him dead
well maybe lots of people wanted him
dead actually uh uh right now it's not
the it's not a kind of hard to tell the
the operation was kind of from one side
it was well organized from the other not
so because the woman that brought in
the explosives did not have an
apparently any exit strategy or was used
without knowing what she's bringing and
so it was kind of destined to be
captured that's not how a professional
intelligence agency's work if they
organize such a hit so right now it's
kind of an open question of course the
Russian already Authority said that
these were the Ukrainian special
agencies who used the some kind of
supporters and traitors inside Russia
that's the official line and I don't
think it's going to change at all
as the investigation progresses how uh
biggest fear is that this military
blogging is there is there someone else
who will come along and take to tasky's
place
oh yes there's a lot of the uh people
competing on that field uh it's a rather
well financed and again because the
official reports coming in from the
defense Ministry uh well not many really
believe them and the influencers and
Military correspondents who which seem
to be a bit more independent many
believe them and they have a following
that's sure and I don't know a different
social pool say the 20 30 percent of the
population actively and Rush actively
supports uh the war effort and this is
Their audience and it's their big
audience good to talk to you Pavel many
thanks indeed probably there in Moscow
thank you